number one the jizzlane maxwell case i
still don't know if that's how you
pronounce her name
uh i'm not sure if anyone knows how to
pronounce her name but i'm just going
with that hundreds of
pages of documents were unsealed last
night some of the documents are
transcripts from a deposition
um with virginia roberts the woman who
alleges that she was
trafficked uh one of many women
trafficked hundreds of women trafficked
by uh
maxwell and epstein and she was a minor
at the time
like so many other women were other
documents uh like
emails and other things are included for
example there's an email between
epstein and maxwell where epstein
appears to be feeding maxwell a
statement that
she can give to the press denying
allegations against her
so stuff like that more interesting are
the names that roberts gives she says
that she was directed to have sex with
be abused by alan dershowitz
former new mexico governor bill
richardson a number of prominent
businessmen and financial guys and she
named bill clinton as a guy who was on
epstein's sex island
uh though she she says she never saw him
commit any crimes
but you know bill clinton clinton on sex
island i think we could
use our common sense on this one my
concern to be honest with you is that
this will be it it's it almost that it
will amount to zero consequences for
any of these scumbags um
one because there's no justice in the
world especially for rich and powerful
people we know that
and also too because there are so many
names and so much information and so
many documents
that i guess i'd be concerned that it
all sort of ends up getting buried under
the avalanche
and there's not any particular focus on
one of these guys or the other
i hope that doesn't happen but that's my
worry and in any case this is just the
tip of the iceberg there are many more
documents out there
and many big names by the way were
redacted on the documents that we saw
so we'll see what happens um the the
names that we really
need to see i think are the people who
are still currently wielding power
most of the names we've gotten are
former this or that
former politicians i want to see the
current ones too
number two st louis prosecutors will not
charge officer darren wilson in the
death of michael brown
that's the headline if it sounds like
i'm reading headlines from 2014 and i've
gotten confused or something and i went
back on google by accident i'm not
this is a headline from last night st
louis prosecutors apparently reviewed
darren wilson's case at the request of
michael brown's family because
this is what prosecutors do now i guess
they're they work as personal attorneys
for the families of alleged victims
um so they they asked him to review the
case and he did
and last night he announced the results
of the review um
that nobody knew was being conducted and
they say there isn't enough evidence to
charge darren wilson
we already knew that of course because
this is now the third investigation into
the shooting
third a grand jury investigated it the
department of justice under barack obama
investigated it
and now a st louis prosecutor has
investigated it
maybe we'll get a you know we'll just
we'll just get an investigation every
every few years like
there's a ceremonial sort of thing
all of these investigations have found
that there is nothing to charge the
officer with
three investigations all come to the
same conclusion
and that's because michael brown was a
violent [ __ ] we can say this now
conclusively
we could have we could have said it six
years ago conclusively
michael brown was a violent criminal who
assaulted a store clerk for no reason
just assaulted him then assaulted a cop
and tried to disarm him
and and died in the process we know that
we know from witnesses we know it from
forensics we know it now from three
investigations what else do we need but
of course none of this matters
it can be investigated 10 more times and
the people who have bought into the
michael brown false narrative will
continue
to buy into it it doesn't matter what
comes out i mean they could release
video footage showing what happened
um which is that we know what happened
michael brown charged darren wilson
and tried to take his weapon um
you know for a lot of forensic evidence
for example
and ballistic evidence uh for example
you know gun power
powder residue on michael brown which
you wouldn't get if wilson was yards
away
shooting brown while he has hands up
saying don't shoot
the gunpowder residue is because uh
brown was right on top of
darren wilson when the gun went off
anyway but it doesn't matter people that
have bought into
the to the false narrative will continue
to
defend it number three the nba started
back up again last night
and uh every player coaching ref knelt
for the anthem
there you go there you can see the
spectacle now charles barkley
during the halftime show provoked a lot
of anger from the left
he now has the cancelled dogs hounding
him for something that he said
about the anthem issue and it was very
provocative extremely controversial i
have to admit
i mean i you know i can't believe
barkley had the gumption to say this
it's pretty shocking listen to this
listen the national anthem mean
different things to different people
i'm glad these guys are all unified but
the people if people don't kneel
they're not a bad person i want to make
that perfectly clear
i'm glad they had unity but if we have a
guy who doesn't want to kneel because
the answer means something to him
he should not be vilified so there you
go if you don't kneel
you're not a bad person that's all he
said
this is now provocative and
controversial
now he's right of course but think about
what it says that
this is a notable statement one that
causes people to get angry and outraged
all he's saying is well you're not
necessarily a total dirtbag if you don't
kneel
and the left treats this as a shocking
claim because they demand of course
total and absolute and unthinking
allegiance to their cause and adherence
to their talking points but think back
even a year ago
a year or two a year ago two years ago
um
you know you had to defend the left had
to defend
people kneeling and now if
there's any defenses it has to be a
defense of people not kneeling
that's how quickly this issue has
shifted
which is one of the advantages of owning
the culture as the left does
number four ellen degeneres who has been
the target of a lot of criticism
recently for
in this case warranted criticism um for
all the countless reports of her being
an abusive sociopath to her staff and
interns
allegedly has sent out a letter variety
tells us
uh it's a it's an emotional letter an
emotional apology letter
to her staff she's taking accountability
apologizing
let's let's here's what she says she
says hey everybody it's ellen
on day one of our show i told everyone
in our first meeting that the ellen
degeneres show would be a place of
happiness
no one would ever raise their voice and
everyone would be treated with respect
obviously something changed and i am
disappointed to learn that this has not
been the case
and for that i am sorry anyone who knows
me knows it's the opposite of what i
believe and what i hope for
i could not have the success i've had
without all of your contributions my
name is on the show and everything we do
i take responsibility for alongside
warner brothers
we immediately begin an internal
investigation and we are taking steps
together to correct the issues as we've
grown exponentially
i've not been able to stay on top of
everything and relied on others to do
their jobs as they knew i'd want them
done
clearly some didn't that will now change
and i'm committed to ensuring this does
not happen again
uh and it goes on from there but that's
basically it that's the gist of it
that's the tone
she's accused of being a horrible boss
who abuses her staff
and her what's her response to that she
blames her staff
this is a total passing of the buck
to her staff who are the ones who
originally accused her of being a bad
boss
and so she's to prove them wrong she's
blaming them
zero accountability zero responsibility
does not apologize at all for her
behavior and lays the blame on her staff
amazing although you know in fairness to
her
you can kind of see why she what else is
she gonna do i mean the only other
option
is to come out and say yeah you know
what i am a total scumbag i'm awful
everything my whole shtick has been fake
uh i'm not a nice person i'm a really
terrible person
i'm sorry about that now i would i would
respect it if she came out and said that
but you know
it's just when you're when the
accusation is essentially
nothing less than you are at the core of
your soul a scumbag
it's going to be a really hard thing to
come out and emit especially when
your entire brand is being the opposite
of that so if she were to admit it then
her brand goes away and uh so it would
take
moral fortitude and courage and
integrity to come out and admit it but
she's not because again scumbag so um
number five finally this isn't really a
headline per se because media matters
complains about us every single day
obviously but
but the latest daily wire clip that
media matters is offended by
is this one from uh ben's show and
they put the video online leftists are
whining about it as usual
uh i did have one thing i wanted to say
about it so let's play the clip listen
to this
hey ben i had a star wars question for
you i generally agree with
i generally agree with your take on the
sequel trilogy i mean even if you liked
one of those episodes the the trilogy as
a whole was just
a failure in my opinion and i noticed
that they had announced that
there's another trilogy scheduled to
begin in 2022 and just your opinion on
in an ideal world uh where disney was
getting it right
what would you like to see that next
trilogy be about so
i've said before that i think that
there's a a great
series we made on darth plagueis i think
that there's a great series we made on
darth bane like
the truth is that what makes the star
wars universe interesting uh
is the is the dark side of the force and
so all the focus on the jedi is actually
a lot less interesting than the focus on
the dark side of the force and its
seductiveness um so you know i guess
that the high republic
is supposed to be they're sort of
prequels it's based on other jedi which
is fine
i mean that's all fine they haven't
really rolled up ruled out exactly
you know how sjw this is going to be i
know that i know that the disney
kind of imagineers have decided that
they're only going to have female heroes
from now on which
is absurd because star wars is
essentially a little boy's property i
mean if you look at like the percentages
of people
who really are huge star wars fans it
breaks down pretty heavily male i would
think
um but i haven't seen what the you know
i'll be curious to see what they do
uh to me the only redeeming feature of
the of the
sequels in in star wars is the fact they
actually finally explained
why rey was such a mary sue like that if
they had not then it would have been
incredibly annoying but yeah i'm curious
to see what they're gonna do i just hope
that they don't do what they what
they've been pledging to do which is
you know kind of throw in a bunch of sjw
nonsense
how dare he how
i for one am shocked and appalled by ben
shapiro's sexism
appalled now granted of course he's
absolutely right
but still uh yeah star wars is primarily
a boy thing
it's most of its fans or boys not
exclusively but mostly
that's just true okay you might not like
it it might make your tummy hurt when
someone says it but it's true it's just
a fact
um but what i really want to say here
just using ben's point as a platform to
jump off
of and into the abyss um
this push in general to inject female
action heroes into every damn movie and
franchise
is annoying for for the same reason and
it's really becoming i mean
you go to netflix or wherever you know
every cop show or action film
or whatever it is almost all of them
have female leads now
and yeah it gets a little silly after a
while um
silly because in many cases these are
still genres with mostly male audiences
the left they're the ones that say the
representation is important right
because uh
people when they're watching films they
want to relate to the characters and
sort of imagine themselves as as those
characters that's the whole reason why
we're told that representation matters
in film well okay
that's also why it's done to turn every
action film with a mostly male audience
into a feminist fever dream
and it's not just the male audience
either i mean i've spoken to many
females who are also rolling their eyes
at the girl power stick and have had
enough of it
um yes these are fiction stories most of
these sorts of films are
not exactly hyper-realistic to begin
with even so the suspension of disbelief
really gets a hell of a workout when
you're watching a 120 pound
hot chick beat up a bunch of brawny 250
pound dudes
right yeah seeing liam neeson in a movie
like taken
single-handedly kill like 300 albanian
sex traffickers
with his bare hands by himself that's
not exactly true to life okay i mean
you're at no risk of mistaking that for
a documentary
though it would be one hell of a
documentary for sure
but take liam neeson out and replace him
with like charlize
theron and the suspension of disbelief
has just
snapped it's it was already strained now
it's snapped
under the pressure under the strain
um and and a kind of cool
and tense but also admittedly ridiculous
action scene
becomes just a straight-up cartoon
now look i i know there's no way to make
this point
without the media matters headline of
daily wire
host outrage by female action stars or
you know whatever
um no not outraged not outraged
this is not outrage when there's a lot
when you get outraged from me you know
it
okay um no i think it's dumb and silly
is what i'm saying
and a huge percentage of the audience
male and female
agrees that it's dumb and silly um
they just won't say it out loud that's
the difference
okay let's go to our daily cancellation
but before we do um
you got to get the reader's pass we've
been telling you about this it's only
three dollars a month
you can start with 99 cents a month if
your first month is 99 cents if you go
to dailywire.com
subscribe and get the readers pass if
you want to get the news
and analysis without all the left-wing
spin then you got to do that you get
access to all of our exclusive op-eds
you also get you can be a part of the
discussion online with other daily wire
members
you receive push notifications you get
access to our mobile app
the mobile ad free access to to all of
our daily wire news exclusive
exclusive op-eds i can't speak and all
of that you get at dailywire.com
subscribe and join today that was a
great read right there
i am a professional folks hey you
uh yeah you you're right you right there
hit the subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated